free whatsapp place from the world trade &
beyond to nice place from disney and covers
bay hill more
is so amazing from example of what we
can a chin draw from decision or
restaurant and consists of inhaling is
skype
[Music]
older  related mouse link to bring back
the speeches derwent extinct index
different national parts in which we
work this one is active from llama
[Music]
the biggest project heart in and you will see
david project santanyes show complicated
from and you cannot be yourself
equal from argentina with the  love in the
artist and incredible groups types of
passion for the world
[Music]
duty and first physics darwin solution and
fridge
go twitter
[Music]
every animal that release hazard
transmitter that way we can follow the
animals make a release
[Music]
[Applause  ]
from caixabank monitor de sanlúcar from
cerebral times a week
like that how they are that into the new in
vain
[Music]
like that
thank
you let's see if she's super asleep she's
perfect
good  no we don't leave her here alone and this
is what we wanted to see a show
that they don't upload vector let's go
they are doing incredible well by their
own show de antithesis a story of taxes
film
we are the northeastern part of
argentina de provins called Corrientes
team de  iberá national park
[Música]
is one of the biggest wetlands or salsa
america and knowledge and productivity that
consists of full [ __ ] anvers retired
and also a lot of speech is that wintek
singing of the century
there were a lot of hunters mass
besides being drawing  bird together faders
and day of internet
physical anders like alligators capybaras
jaguars with their skins
hour vision this try to help rivers of
dance diversity extension classes start
arpey without a doubt in an argentina isba
protecting bodies let that way' wikreate
worthy sion to the liberated park angurri
store  of the cndh multiva introducing
pistons pisces darwin texting leave
fluvial for you ecosystem funkshion
[Music]
we are working in di  fferent places in
liberal software of the ix and frame
places were regular 2010 thing speech
one day with the low economic activity
by the local and by the cangués show
benefits from that for free with a
tubey created and wildlife and starting to
recover
we are the spirit  award very common 2 ones
of curry cover there will be a duty and
cover bahienses
by astros late project we have to
bring animals frank captivity
we are getting to one corinthians that
we fight for the project in these 40 and
wilson java giant sand and chat networks
presented every year the
serratus animal of the center will be seen our ordering
by fans is matter of winkel by
vouchers
the animal day is treated from captivity
start the journey in the project in the
calling
well everything barbaric well let's go ali ihsan
argentinian biology and see the one  that
takes care of all these animals until
they are ready to go to the field to be released
yo salí when the animals a ride barberis
mont ventoux bife with  the special milk
cerebral times and day
i
[Music]
all against the background attending in the
beginning some deals in his time as
sadam and marcela that the first milestones
many died for aspiring to much
success in meaning
[Music]
yes
to
[Music]
66 7
when they are back end of a heart nes
ciudad transmitter
we can release time in the world
[Music]
the giant otter and sana der spiegel when
completely extinct and in argentina
because of hunting because we destroy
habitats blogging
a
easyfairs introduction session
projects run for high and others
cindy's buck every summer another one without captivity
in argentina
[Music]
his coco from first mail of the project
keys sting from 40
[Music]
and what information from mark and one and
finish from 40 we will give him his freedom
to act and le pen
outside female that also came from europe
is waiting for him that's a alondra
qué alondra they don't know where
there's a long way for them to learn how
to raise the caps and o  ne state ready we
will be bridge to hell is time in the
wild
[Music]
hui de makos we have the mouse hard work
for in enable and tim dowse animals
monster spikes on the side and bring the
project of the champion his short wildlife
resource center
strings hang  y el software live small
case without the possibility offline
you're not only have to change cerdá
jets but we also have to teach me how to
fly
[Música]
y cambia one two years individually
in which we train the animals del campo
frank aptv  ting lu surviving the wild
[Music]
all these spark gration processes
rewarding process can not be without the
support of the local communities
or the cam things
with pellegrini is small town by day see
a park that had saved words
austria and in fort street cut the  ranking
and rise film now since the crazies I
gave us provincial research of the main
economic activity and psycho tourism
we have grown up with all this culture and
the place is proud to be able to
show it
since around the park there are many
stories of lives that have changed and an
entire town began a process of
change finding respect for its
nature
[Music]
people big and round of what they had
and now and people who tested del home
town and day  start to run and with tourism
business as local guys
[Music]
from yuste knowledge and they can be proud
a type of camps are different from the
world to see what they know
[Music]
and today they live in the place that they liberate today they
are proud because  they can stay
in their place of origin without leaving where they
lived all their lives
it allows them to have an income that
allows the families that
are still inside to live
[Music]
3er forty years ago we have that the
best thing you can do  to preserve
spaces and notes in the end
now we say that the best thing you can
do in sanction they say
you can do this bieber and active
said that marijuana the perimeter type by
vinsac web software center
of spirit air supplies  lines of the iaj andan
twitter of pump shipyard is going to be careful
starting with the top' predators time
they awards or small caps world tour here
[Music]
I have a pawn
I want nothing and someone is nearby or
we are all calm
in the back perimeter and not anymore sir
I don't see it and from the jaguar reintroduction
project we did complicated anhembí
shows project how we build a bear and big
reintroduction center mary hughes pence
and ari football looks like us 'jurassic
park' ford jaguars
so far away i have fun animals and these
reintroduction center that  we think
ready to be released
we hope that during desert we will have
the first jaguars living free liberal
andar will be like the connection of the
world in roger picos hijas never been
danby ford
we have to one of the female jaguars
mark i want to the biggest  in closer
order inside action center and be
check step for the project because
it's almost cold power management south
lake pin o ready living for it
and see all this  you hear
beyond the infrastructure that you see it
is in sight that it is magnificent to see the
progress of the projects
excites a little neighbor
the yaguareté project to the unusual I say
leave the unique and something spiritual going
around there is a magic that is going
around  to this project in the
communities
today is a nothing full of emotion of
joy of uncertainty of how it
will go then happy and proud of this
day
[Music]
maybe not with the bring back of kingston it
is pisces of sexting
[Music]
but still  and it's proactive conservation
action
prince royce yours blue
[Music]
well I said marcos flying group
when I yes it's the one from ford but that bird
can make
[Music]
kitts many many of work with in
individual show is not just to mac osx
flying bag a  lot of story behind those
incredible colors
[Music]
we don't living cities will i be the
place where we are the world we can
neighbors del local type of heart the
ones erc previous stories about the
animals a  bout the places
[Music] a
long time ago really proud edward
developing a woods champions that we
don't need to destroy nation deja a
better life quality
[Music]
news fila grade satisfaction that we are
fixing as a services out of the vaccines
la measure  de paz
[Music]
now and always english and I was so great
the jaguar without a place at the one textile
[Music]
what we cannot be seen will philips lite
locating ebre
at the base
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm liberal to a pitchfork I'm a clear step to
win it's current the moon
takes away the candle I shoot
on the crutch I'm waiting for
San Marcos and Wade and Bosh today
I'm Antonio Marín
caramba
[Music]
r
goddess la  goddess fell inside in the middle of
august in fernando
but
[Music]